what's it like um
co-headlining after leaving strange
music with tech
uh it's really cool man because like um
you know just stranger's family you know
right um no matter what we've been
through you know
the strange fan base is very [ __ ]
loyal it's like ritz man we miss you
like yeah you know like i didn't go
nowhere yeah like drive [ __ ] gone no
project since i left yeah we're still
friends like everything's cool i'm just
trying to make some money for myself and
just like further myself in business
it's like you know you you know you rent
a home to somebody you or you're a
homeowner you try to rent like six more
and you start doing your real estate
[ __ ] yeah yeah you dropped you've
dropped four projects since you left
yeah yeah yeah put a crown on it chris
uh richardson's uh picture perfect and
uh sos and i got a lot more coming so
it's like um
you know yeah either way it's one of
those things you drop four projects on
strange music oh on streams no i mean i
mean i'm saying like that says a lot
like you dropped yeah two thousand
saying you dropped you dropped the same
amount of [ __ ] really project-wise
from the entire time you were on strange
for sure for sure since you've left
ando's got yeah since i left yeah for
sure and like but it was a different
game then you know different time
different uh different way things are
delivered to the consumer and stuff um
but man the thing is that people don't
realize man you get so caught up in the
who's who and who's with what label and
who's cool who all this music [ __ ]
at the end of the day is business and
i'm i'm friends with tech and travis and
everybody on that label so i got love
for them you know what i'm saying like
so it's not like they look at this man
you left strange blah blah it's like yo
man this is business man like we're like
these are my friends right